So my name is Dan Arielli and I'm the
James B Duke professor of psychology and
behavioral economics at Duke University.
So I became interested in online dating
because one of the people who were
sitting in an office next to me was
incredibly miserable and he was an
assistant professor.
He just moved to the university where I
was at a.
He was spending long hours.
He was not finding anybody to date.
He was couldn't date students at the
university who was a professor and he
didn't have time to go outside,
you know,
we will not particularly social bunch,
he was,
he was basically stuck and all I did it
was a very promising way to think about
this solution for a marketplace that
wasn't working very well and he tried
online dating and he was just failing
miserably continuously.
So that kind of piqued my curiosity
about it.
And then I started looking at online
dating.
So I started looking by registering
myself and looking at other people.
And then I said,
let,
let me ask some of my friends to enroll
because I didn't ask them to really
enroll.
They just took the profile sheets and
they ask people,
could you fill those out but without
your name,
and they took people that I liked more
than I liked less and they took a profit
and I tried to figure out who they tell
the difference.
You know,
and imagine that you did this.
Imagine you went to 50 people you really
like and 50 people you only like so,
so,
and you asked all of them to feel this
profit.
Then you took this 100 profiles and you
try to sort them into piles.
It turns out we were terrible at this,
right?
So this is kind of an initial
observation is that something is going
wrong in this,
in this market,
and then went a step further,
did some studies with online data is
about how much they enjoyed it and what
they were getting from it until the
final stage we.
I figured out,
I thought I knew what was going on,
which is that online dating site assume
that people are easy to describe on
searchable attributes.
They think that we're like digital
cameras that you can describe somebody
by their height and weight and political
affiliation and so on,
but it turns out people are much more
like wine that when you taste the wine,
you could describe it,
but he's not a very useful description,
but you know if you like it or don't,
is the complexity and the completeness
of the experience that tells you if
you're like a person or not.
And these breaking into attributes turns
out not to be very informative.
So in the last stage of this process,
we created a different website and that
different websites allow people to
experience other people without all of
these attributes and we show that this
is actually much better and would lead
to much more,
much higher probability of going on a
second on the real date afterwards.
So.
So it kind of goes from an observation
to a little study to a bit more details
and finally proposing some kind of
solution of something that I think would
actually work better.
So the site basically looks at real
dates and think about what real dates
are.
They're not about sitting in a room and
interviewing each other about question.
They're often about experiencing.
It's in something together in the real
world and I think it's because if you
and I went out and we went somewhere,
I would look at how you react to the
outside world,
what music you like,
what you don't like,
what kind of pictures you like,
what kind of images,
how do you react to other people,
what do you do in the restaurant and
through all these kinds of non explicit
aspects,
I will learn something about,
you know,
I would feel that I'm learning something
about you and the online system we
created was very much like that.
It was about you came up when you got
the little Avatar is square or triangle,
some color and you wanting to a virtual
space which you could explore it and you
could see lots of stuff.
There were pictures and images and there
were words and there were movies and
they were bands.
There's all kinds of stuff and you could
go and when you came to another little
Avatar,
you could start chatting and you would
chat about something.
It wasn't about interviewing when you
went to school in what's your religion?
It was about talking about something
else and it turns out it gave people
much more information about each other
and they're much more likely to want to
meet each other for the first eight and
four for a second date.
So I think that online dating is an
incredibly unsatisfying experience.
In fact,
when we do surveys to understand what
people do,
they the basic trade off is for each six
hours of searching for people and
emailing them and you get one cup of
coffee and it's not as if people enjoy
online dating.
It's not as if they have fun searching
people in a writing blogs for them.
I mean imagine that you basically had to
drive six hours,
three hours each week to have coffee
with somebody and you know,
coffee usually ends up with just coffee.
It's an incredibly unsatisfying
experience.
So I,
I think it's a really bad.
It's really bad system.
On top of that,
there's another thing is,
which I imagine they gave you the search
criteria which asks you to search by
height and weight and income and all of
those things.
You're going to use it.
That's what I give you to search.
There's a million people out there.
You want to limit them to $3,000.
That's what we're going to.
That's what you're going to use,
and because of that,
I think actually people become much more
superficial than we think they're.
So here's an example.
It turns out that women really care
about men's height.
I'm five nine.
If I wanted to be as attractive as
somebody who's five,
10,
right?
Another inch,
I would have to make about 35,
$40,000 more a year.
That's another money for one inch.
At the same time,
it turns out that men care a lot about
women's BMS.
In fact,
they want women to be slightly on the
rack sick.
It's like 18 and a half and you look at
women's attractiveness.
It goes really up at low BMI and really
drops below that.
Now people online look incredibly
superficial,
they look at hair color and they look at
height and they look at income and
that's basically it and attractiveness
of course,
and you can ask is it because that's all
people care about or is that because
that's what the system is giving them to
search for and I think it's because of
combination,
right?
Sure.
We also prefer,
sure we do care about attractiveness and
in heightened income,
and these are,
these are features for us,
but they think they're exaggerated by
the way the system is creative.
Imagine you were looking for something
else.
Imagine you were looking for eh digital
cameras and imagine that I only allow
you to search on mega pixels and the f
stop for the Lens,
right?
These things will become incredibly
important.
Right?
And if I drop some things from the
search,
they will become as if they're not
important or much less important.
So I think part of the problem is that
the systems don't give us the right
information that we need and because of
this,
I think the experience of online dating
is generally unsatisfying.
I mean,
think about it,
how many millions of people are
participating in this activity and a
marriage rates has not increased.
Divorce rate has decreased.
I mean,
not really much has happened because of
the Atlantic.
At the same time.
I think it's incredibly important,
right?
We,
the dating market is perhaps the only
market that we moved from a centralized
market to a decentralized markets.
You know,
we used to have a into your parents used
to tell you what to do.
All this is gone.
Now you have to fend for yourself.
On top of that,
we move a lot,
right?
You,
you go to one place for Undergrad,
then you go to Grad school,
then you move to another city for a job
to easily remove.
Again,
you have no time to create a social
network.
We work long hours,
so it really assist them where we don't
have time to find people for ourselves.
It's very,
it's taboo to date people at the
workplace.
Uh,
the social networks are weaker in the
physical world.
We move all the time and we don't have
a,
our parents to tell us what to do.
So,
so online dating are incredibly
important.
They could be central and crucial and we
need to create them because it's really
a miserable situation for most single
people at the same time.
The ones that we have created and they
all look the same.
Basically,
there are no real differences between
them.
The ones that we're creating,
I just not that useful.
Assortative mating is the idea that if
you took all men and you rank them on
how attractive they are from the most
attractive to the least attractive and
you write it all women from the most
you can think about attractiveness is
built,
being built from lots of stuff,
right?
It's not just beauty.
It could be beauty and intelligence and
so on,
but if you created this,
it was mostly about beauty,
but you know,
if you created that,
it turns out that the most attractive
would date,
the most attractive,
the middle attractive with basically the
middle and the low data low.
Now there could be slight deviations,
but that's what happened and why?
Because if you're at the top and you're
a guy,
you can pick anybody you want,
so you would pick a woman who was on the
top and if she's at the top she could
pick anybody she wants you will pick
you.
So another question is what happened to
the people in the middle,
you know,
most of us,
what,
what happens to people in the middle,
how do we make sense of where we are in
the social hierarchy?
And for me that thought actually became
a very kind of crucial in the parents
when I got injured.
So here's what happened.
You,
you grow up and you have some kind of
space in society and you know,
basically where you are and you know,
who date you and who would not take you,
who's kind of outside of your league in
general terms and you know,
where you fit in the social hierarchy.
And,
and,
and I knew I wasn't a social hierarchy,
but one day I got badly injured and you
know,
I couldn't think about romantic stuff
for a long time.
But when I could,
um,
office and I started wondering about
where do I fall now in the social
hierarchy,
I'll try to think about,
do I fall in the same place?
I'm kind of the same person inside,
but I look much less attractive.
Right.
And with the women who were dating
before we keep on dating me now.
And I said,
why would they,
they have other options,
right?
I'm not the only guy in the world.
So,
so it was kind of a very difficult
concept for me to think about where do I
fall?
I felt differently on the social
hierarchy.
I basically lost my space all of the
time and I was trying to understand how
these social dance happened and how we
find our place.
And I was really wondering about where
would I find my own mate,
where,
where would I fit in this in this scale?
And there's a lot of personal
complexities with it,
but eventually it led me to a study in
the study was really asking the question
of how do we make sense of where we fit
in the hierarchy and the basically kind
of multiple explanations,
right?
You could say you never adjust.
You never.
If you kind of in the middle range or
the low range and you only are.
You have to date somebody else who's in
the middle range.
You never make peace with it.
You wake up every morning,
you look at your partner across your
shoulder and you say,
well,
that's the best I could.
I really wanted more.
Sadly,
no.
I have to admit my limitations.
That's the most I could do.
That means you don't adapt.
It could be that you adapt.
It could be that,
for example,
if you're unattractive,
you start looking at other features that
are unattractive and see them as
attractive.
You remember the story from cree love
when you have this,
this wolf city say grapes over the fence
and he tries to get them and he can't
get them and eventually said,
ah,
there was sour anyway,
and he goes to eat something else.
Right?
So you could imagine that if you are
attractive yourself,
you start valuing.
If you're a woman,
you start valuing short men who are bald
with bad teeth,
right?
I mean you just say,
these are really wonderful features.
I like hairy chest.
I like bullheaded.
You basically change what you like and
that actually helps you adjust.
Or You can imagine that you start liking
other things.
You stop paying attention to
attractiveness and start paying
attention to other things.
So we tried that in an experiment.
Initially we went to this website called
hot or not.
It's a wonderful website.
You see pictures of people and you
decide you rank them on a scale from
zero to 10 about how attractive they are
and then you see how you rated this
person,
how other people rate them.
But the nice feature about this website
is that if I reach people,
the website knows how I was rated as
well because I have my picture there as
well.
By the way,
I'm not rated very high,
I think like six point four.
But there are people who are rating,
you know how the rating and you know how
the rated.
So now the question is the people who
are providing the rating,
there are people who are really
attractive,
that are providing writing and people
who are really unattractive,
providing the rating.
And the first thing you can ask is do
they have different ratings?
Are the people who are inherently
unattractive?
Do they see beauty differently?
And the answer is no.
We all see beauty in the same way.
The people who are nine rate people the
same way as the people who are for in
the hotness rating.
So,
so people don't change their sense of
beauty.
Now you could say,
uh,
so maybe they don't adjust at all.
Maybe they don't adapt the people who
are for coupons looking for the people
who are with nine or maybe they adapt
some other way.
So hot the note has another feature
which is the cycle of meet me in which
you see pictures of people and you say,
do I want to meet them or not?
Now it's not just reading.
It's about also thinking about the
probability that you will be accepted or
turn down and it's not so embarrassing
to be turned online,
but it's still a little bit
embarrassing.
So the question is that people who are
nine,
will they approach different people than
the people who are for.
And the answer is absolutely yes.
The people who are for basically
approached people who are four or five,
the people who are nine approach people
who are nine or 10 people are a little
optimistic.
They approach a little too high,
but they basically know the rage.
So what happened is people know the
range,
they know where they are in the social
hierarchy,
but the same time they see beauty at the
same thing.
So what happens?
So how people solve it,
they wake up every morning feeling bad
or do they solve it in some way?
So the last step we did the speed dating
events.
We get people to do a speed dating event
and we asked them to rate other people
or lots of attributes,
not just attractiveness,
but all kinds of other things and what
we saw was the people who are very
attractive,
cared more about attractiveness.
This is like one of the dominating
criteria.
They want to date somebody who is
attractive.
While the people who are unattractive
basically say we don't care so much
about attractiveness.
We want people who are kind and have a
good sense of humor.
So what happened is that the way people
adapt the people at the low end of the
scale is by changing your priorities and
office and saying,
I want people with different set of
attributes I don't care so much about,
but I want somebody who's client good
hearted with a good sense of humor.
And that's actually the story for the
patients.
So that's the story of how we are coming
into a social hierarchy in a certain
place and based on our circumstances
come to understand differently what we
want and don't want and how we view the
world in a way that is compatible with
where we are in the social hierarchy.
So I don't know if you've had the
experience of going into a Kia,
but uh,
I,
I go from time to time and the last
thing I did was a builder,
a toy chest for my,
for my kids.
And when I got home with this box
actually set up boxes and they started
assembling them.
Uh,
for me,
the instructions were very unclear and I
kept on screwing things and screwing
them wrongly and had to disassemble it,
put it back together.
And so on.
By the end of the day,
I worked a lot.
It was not a particularly beautiful
piece of furniture,
but I was actually quite attached to it.
What did.
I think that's kind of the interesting
idea is that when you put a lot of
yourself into it,
some sweat and energy and anger,
not even frustration,
you end up loving the end product a bit
more.
We tried to do this with experiments and
we got people to build the Legos in and
all kinds of things and the first thing
we found was that if there was an
origami that you build in Origami that
somebody else built,
you think that yours is much,
much more beautiful.
Not only is it more beautiful,
you willing to pay much more for it.
Right now.
The question is why you could imagine I
built an origami that is uniquely good
for me and you the other origami is not
so it's unique to me.
It's not about the fact that I kind of
wrongly evaluated.
He just has some features that are
particularly like.
So we ask people to predict how other
people would pay for it and it turns out
people are really wrong with it.
Not only do we like more the origami we
make,
we think other people would love them as
well.
And you can think about kids like this,
right?
I have two wonderful kids.
I love them dearly.
I think they're amazing when we go to a
party and they dance or do something.
I can't believe that any of the parents
would want to do anything but look at my
kids.
Right?
And that's the issue right there.
My kids,
I think they're are wonderful,
but not only that,
I think that other people should see
them as wonderful as I see them in the
same thing happened with origami or with
everything we make.
Not only do we overvalue it,
we think that everybody will share our,
our perspective.
And
this of course creates both
opportunities for better things and
opportunities for mistakes.
Right?
So if you're,
if you're a company and you can create
things that people would actually put
something of themselves into it and
actually value it more,
that's a great thing to do,
right?
Uh,
there's lots of opportunities for
tailoring and custom made and use a
design on the web.
It's also about cooking for yourself and
doing your own garden and fixing things
yourself because we might not understand
that if we do something ourselves,
we would like it more,
but the fact is we we likely would do
the same thing,
but of course there's the downside and
the downside is if we create something,
we ended up loving it,
perhaps too much.
We don't sit it in an objective way and
as a consequence we can make mistakes as
well.
And that's actually a general comment
about rationality and irrationality.
Rationality and irrationality is not
always bad.
It's not always that the irrational
person is better than irrational.
It's a mixture,
right?
It's really wonderful that we can love
our kids so much that that's why they
actually get to live and we care about
them,
but at the same time,
our blindness to them,
to them or to the weaknesses can
actually create some negative
consequences as well.
So I think the world would actually be
quite terrible if everybody would be,
would be perfectly rational.
And you know,
when you ask people this question
initially,
you said,
Oh yes,
I want everybody to be irrational,
but the fact is that I pick the title,
the upside of irrationality,
because I think there's a lot of
wonderful things about your rationality.
I'll give you two examples.
The first one is imagine that you left
your wallet on your desk and you went
out for lunch.
What are the odds that somebody will
steal it right?
And now think about what are the odds
that somebody would steal it if
everybody you worked with was perfectly
rational.
If everybody was constantly doing the
cost benefit analysis,
if that's all what people were doing,
they would pass by your desk.
They would say,
hey,
nobody's here.
Nobody's looking.
I can steal this and have no chance of
being caught.
Let me do that.
Right?
In fact,
if we lived in a society where everybody
was just maximizing their own self
interest all the time,
it will be quite a terrible place to
live.
Here's another example.
Imagine a game we call the trust game
and then I'll tell you about the trust
game.
We'd revenge.
So imagine two players,
player a and player B,
and the trust game looks like this.
We tell player a player,
you have $20,
you could do two things,
you can either go home or you can give
your money to player b and you don't
know who play B is and you'll ever meet
them.
If you send your money to play or a B
player b will get $80,
the money will quadruple magically
underway.
And now play a beat who decide to do two
things?
They could go home with $80,
in which case you will get nothing or
they could send you back half the money.
Now think about this situation.
Imagine you player a and you ask
yourself what would play or be do if
player b was perfectly rational,
what would they do?
They will go home with all the money,
right?
They will maximize the self interest.
Why would they give you back any money?
So if you thought that player b was
perfectly rational,
would you send them the money?
Of course not,
right?
So the rational prediction is that
player b will never send the money back,
and because of that,
player a will never trust him to start
with.
Turns out people are much nicer than
economic theory predicts.
There's a good chance that player a,
we'll send them money and a good chess
player.
B,
we'll send half the money back.
And if you were a player b,
you can just imagine.
Imagine you just got in the mail.
Somebody that says,
Hey,
here's what happened.
Would you send the money back or not?
Right?
Most people would do it.
So people,
this is the case when people are
national economic theory,
but imagine your player a and you send
them money to player B and player b took
the money and left and now I come to you
and I say,
really?
Salary player a,
you lost all your money.
But I tell you what,
if you go into a checking account and
you get more money out and you give it
to me for every dollar you give me,
I will go.
I will hunt,
play a beat down and I'll take $2 away
from them.
You give me $2,
a 109,
take four,
you gave me 10 $100 and take from them
and the question is would you lose more
of your own money to exert revenge on
them?
You just lost $20 and you can lose even
more to exact revenge on them.
And everybody who had a divorce or
breakup know the answer right?
When we feel betrayed,
we would spend lots and lots of money to
inflict even more pain on the other
side.
And when Ernst Fair in some of his
friends did it work like this,
they basically put people in an imaging
so they could image people's brains
while they were executing and plotting
revenge and what they saw was that the
activity of revenge was rewarding.
It was pleasurable.
Now again,
it's irrational.
Why would it be rewarding and
pleasurable?
Think about it this way.
Imagine that you and I were living on a
desert island and imagined I had the
mango and you wanted my mango and
imagine I kind of looked.
I was away for a minute and you could
still my mango if you thought that the
only thing I was doing is a cost benefit
analysis.
You would say,
Hey,
if I steal Dan's mango and run far away
enough,
he will do the cost benefit analysis.
You will decide not to chase me,
not to find out what happened.
He'll just go and get the new mango and
under those circumstances a good chance
you'll take my mango away,
but what if I was a revengeful type?
What if you knew that if you stole my
mango,
I will not sleep and I will not rest.
I will hunt you down.
It doesn't matter how long it will take
me and how far I have to run and how
many nights I will not sleep.
I will hunt you down.
I'll take my mango and all your bananas
in your goat and your whatever,
whatever it is under that condition,
you will probably not start with me to
start with.
Right?
You will not take anything with me.
So the way to understand it is that
trusting is irrational,
but we do it.
Revenge is irrational,
but we do it and we do it because trust
and revenge are actually two sides of
the same coin.
Trust is incredibly important for
society.
Imagine how we would live in a society
without trust,
but to have trust,
we also have to have revenge and those
things together make sense.
They're both irrational,
but they're both make sense and they
actually help us to live in a better
society.
So would I prefer a society when
everybody's rational?
I don't think so.
Not In a.
not in a long shot.
One of the things that I think companies
do to a large degree that makes very
little sense is the use of focus groups.
So think about what a strange idea is
that we take 10 people who know
basically nothing about your project and
you put them in a room and you let them
talk for awhile and then you take the
whatever they came up with as a
consequence of these two hours of random
thinking and you base your strategy on
it to a large degree.
And,
and I don't want to say that focus
groups are always useless and also
uninformative,
but I think that taking this data and
then realizing it as extensively as
companies do,
I think,
I think it's crazy in many ways.
And the reason I think companies do it
is because when these people create a
sentence or an idea,
it's very easy to say,
joe focus group 17 said this and it can
help you create a form,
formulate an idea around it.
When if you said 87 percent of the
people said x,
he just doesn't have a face,
he doesn't have a desire,
it's just not as concrete and therefore
people are not as excited about the,
about the notion.
So I think the focus group is incredibly
useful as a persuasive attempt,
uh,
to,
to tell people what to do,
but as a way to find out information,
it's not as useful as people think it
is.
The other thing that really puzzles me
is that the companies,
how little they understand about how
incentives really work.
So the,
the biggest expenditure for almost any
company is salaries.
And you ask people,
what do you know about the relationship
between salaries and performance?
The answer is nothing.
Right?
And the question is why don't they study
anything?
Why don't they studied?
Why don't they try different
performance,
different incentive level and see how it
influenced a performance.
And they often say,
well the law kind of laws and if we have
pay some people one way and another way
we might be sued.
And,
but in the last two years with all these
questions about bonuses and so on,
I've gone to many companies and said,
why don't we at least do some surveys?
Why don't we at least see how happy
people are on the months where they give
them,
you give them their bonus and how
productive they are.
And the answer I got 100 percent of the
time is that people are really miserable
in both the season.
And because of that they don't want to
ask them any more questions.
And I said,
if people are miserable in bonuses and
shouldn't it mean that you should study
it,
understand it and try to prevent it from
next for next year.
And say,
well,
well not this year,
this year was really miserable.
Maybe next year come back to us next
year.
But if you think about it,
it's really incredible.
Now how do companies decide about
compensation?
They look at what other companies are
doing and try to equate compensation to
what other companies are doing it,
but it's a place of the blind leading
the blind.
Right?
And then if we pay five percent more,
other people will start doing it,
but the real question is how do you pay
in?
How do you get people to care about
their work and become more productive
and be happier at their work?
And the answer is not simply that more
money is better,
more money can be part of the equation,
but it's also the question of how do you
give that money?
You give it a bonus to give this a fixed
salary.
You give it as a part of the benefits.
Maybe you give benefits for the gym.
Do you send people on vacation to the
Bahamas?
And it turns out that there are ways to
use money that is economically less
efficient,
but actually get people to be more
motivated,
care more,
and actually become more productive.
So this is a you can think of is the
Baby Jessica Fair trade.
When Baby Jessica fell to the well and
she really suffered and her parents must
have been incredibly miserable.
She got more CNN and coverage in Rwanda
and for right then the question is why?
Why does this happen and why do people
care so much?
And it turns out there's the research on
what's called the identifiable victim
effect and the question is if you have,
how many lives are at stake and how much
do we care you would that as more live?
So at stake,
we would care more maybe in the linear
relationship or maybe we will care more
in the beginning and they'll be kind of
a diminishing return.
Like we wouldn't care if it's 100 or a
thousand,
but we care a lot of the bottom range.
But it turns out the function is
different.
We care a lot about individual life and
you care less and less as the pie is the
number of people become bigger and this
goes to kind of an observation is both
stallion and Mother Teresa said,
Stalin said one death is a tragedy,
a million deaths is a statistic,
and mother Theresa said in the same
spirit,
if I look at the masters,
I will never act.
If I look at the one I will and both of
them basically portray this idea that
what happened when we kind of think
about recruiting ourselves to act
against something,
it's not about our mind thinking.
It's something about to call calculated,
thought about what's worthwhile and
what's the cost benefit analysis.
It's about our heart.
It's about our emotions and the question
is what can activate emotion and it
turns out that an individual case can
get us to care versus a big set of cases
just becomes statistics.
So this beautiful results by a depth
small and George Loewenstein and Paul
Slovic that basically say,
here's one girl in Africa who's hungry.
How much money would you give her?
And then two other people,
they say,
here's the problem of hunger in Africa,
they have 3 million kids in Sudan and
are 5 million kids here and this.
How much money would you give?
And people give half as much to Africa.
Then they give to the single girl Rokia.
It actually gets worse because you said
if people give more when it's emotional,
then when you statistical,
what happens when we give both
inflammation will say,
hey,
here's one girl Rokia.
Think,
see how sad she is and how much money
could help her.
By the way,
there's 5 million more like her.
What will happen?
It goes down.
It turns out that every time you
activate cognition,
calculation,
thoughtfulness,
you turn off the emotion.
People care less and give much less.
And of course this explains a little
bit,
Eh,
the,
the kind of imbalance between what we
give to and what we don't give to.
So think about how difficult it is to
get money for prevention of diseases,
prevention of malaria or prevention of
diarrhea or deworming kids in the world.
You know,
lots of kids have have worms.
And it turns out that those things are
incredibly important,
incredibly useful.
You can actually get people to be much,
much healthier,
but it's not motivating,
right?
Deworming of kids or you know,
a million kids in India just doesn't
make you feel warm and fuzzy or
preventing kids in the future from
getting malaria is again,
not that exciting.
But if you can help one person,
specific concrete get something,
we all get very excited from it.
So there is a real imbalance between
what really matters and what we care
about and what we give time and money
to.
If you run the not for profit,
of course you want to build on this on
the Russian art is because you care
about your non for profit.
And I think the example here is of
course the American cancer society.
They've done a really good job.
First of all,
the word cancer is great in,
in,
in a minute,
recruiting where right?
It's an,
it's an awful disease.
The second thing is the word survivor is
really good.
And the third thing they do is they
create an incredible fear from cancer.
I mean,
the truth is we all have lots of cancer
and we all usually get,
get over it.
I mean,
some,
some people of course it dawned,
but in our lifetime we'll all have
cancerous cells and in most cases it
will be just part of the deal of living,
um,
but,
but they created these really negative
association that now everybody who had
cancer,
even if it was not malignant,
that will not cause them to die or it
was so slow,
it will take 50 years to develop and
they're called everybody at cancer
survival.
And because of that,
everybody who knows them and everybody
who cares about them start caring about
about cancer.
Now,
uh,
you know,
it's kind of interesting because they
basically have mastered this issue,
right?
They've mastered making it central
focal,
created very strong fear about,
about cancer and,
and caring embodied.
Then they basically get a lot of money
and if you look at them as a non for
profit,
they are an incredibly wealthy non for
profit.
In fact,
there are other non for profit field
that they're Kansas.
It is getting so much money that people
just don't give to other causes because
they give so much to that cause and now
there's all kinds of movements to
basically stop the status as a nonprofit
because they're so wealthy and they
spend so much money on salaries and,
and so on.
But,
but in a sense of understanding human
psychology,
uh,
they are the top.
Basically.
There's lots of lots of behavior like
this.
So,
so the,
the basic,
uh,
essence is a trade off between the short
term and long term.
Kind of a personal story about this,
uh,
when,
when I was in hospital a long time ago,
I got to liver disease from bad lunches,
fusion and for a long time they didn't
know what it was.
And from time to time I would get some
liver
infection.
And it was,
it was kind of bad in about seven years
after I got to India,
that was already out in the hospital.
I was in Grad school.
I had another flare up.
I checked myself into a hospital and
they found out it was hepatitis C and
they,
there was an experimental treatment at
that time called Interferon,
so why don't you try,
why don't you try this?
I was very happy to try it because you
know who would want to die from liver
cirrhosis and they basically got these
injections.
I had to inject myself three times a
week for a year and a half and these
injections basically symbolize for me,
they kind of the essence of the human
condition.
He was an injection that could
potentially be very useful for me 30
years later,
but what happened is that he also had
very bad side effects,
so every time I would take an that would
be sick for about 16 hours.
Vomiting,
shaking fever,
nothing really terrible compared to
liver cirrhosis,
but for sure unpleasant and now and
here's the question,
liver really important.
Injections,
slightly important but now in for
certain and that's basically the trade
off we have everything.
It's about saving,
not good for now,
good for the future.
Exercising,
not good for now,
good for the future.
Dieting,
not good for now,
good for the future,
safe sex,
not so good for now,
good for the future.
Lots of things have this trade off in
terms of that when we face these
tradeoffs,
we often do what's called the present
bias focus.
We focus on the present too much and as
a consequence,
we undermine the long term,
the long term effect.
This is the problem with Adam and eve
and you can ask yourself,
you know,
who would ever give in eternity in the
garden of Eden for an apple?
Well,
if you ever texted and drive at the same
time,
you basically have done this mistake,
right?
And most people have texted while
driving and,
and,
and why do we do it?
It's not because we weigh the cost
benefit analysis and we say it's a
really good idea to text while driving.
It's because we're tempted at the moment
to do something that we realized it was
really stupid from the longterm
perspective.
Now,
back to my story,
when I,
after a year and a half,
uh,
there were two pieces of good news.
The first one was that my liver was
working fine and there was no trace of
the disease,
and the second thing is that doctors
told me was that I was the only patient
that I ever had who took the medication
on time.
The question is,
how could I do it?
Do I have nerves of steel and might not
succumb to the imputation?
The answer is,
of course,
we also come to temptation all the time.
There's no difference,
but what I did was I found a trick in my
trick is that I love movies.
If I had time,
I watched lots and lots of movies,
so every Monday,
Wednesday and Friday on the way to
school,
I would stop at a video store.
I would run two or three videos.
I really wanted to see how with carry
them in my backpack the whole day.
Anticipating watching them,
I would get home,
I would give myself the injection,
I would push a video in.
I would get the bucket that we get the
blanket.
I was already to the side effect and I
will start the video immediately.
I would wait for the side effect to
settle in.
I started immediately.
Now you can ask yourself,
do they really care about my liver?
And the answer is no.
The fact is that delivery is really
important in me and all the other
patients should have kept on taking your
medication on time because of the liver,
but it wasn't strong enough.
So what did I do?
I substituted deliver with movies.
Now you might say this is a stupid idea.
Liver is really important.
Movies not that crucial.
If you asked me what do I prefer,
movies or liver,
you know,
there's no question,
but because deliveries in the future,
it was vastly discounted because the
movies were in immediately.
It was actually motivating me and we
call this reward substitution when I
behave as if I care about my liver by
actually caring about movies and I think
there's actually a big lesson though.
You can think about how do we get people
to care about their health and money and
a longevity and so on.
Can we really get people to wake up
everyday and care about those things?
That will happen 30 years from now.
The answer is really very difficult,
expensive and unlikely,
but can we find other reward
substitution?
Can we get people to behave because of
other things in a way that would make
them behave as if they care about the
things that are doing for.
So why do people go to the gym,
right?
Do they really wake up every morning
worrying about how they will look,
feel like 30 years from now?
Probably not,
but can we get them to do some of these
about the moment that actually get them
to behave because they do something that
makes them care about behaviors if they
care about something else.
And I think that reward substitution
actually provides a general answer to
lots of problems in,
in human behavior.
We just need to find out what these
rewards can be.
Absolutely.
So if you think about the question of
trust and revenge,
that's a great example,
right?
The fact is that we're live in a
society.
We're inherently social animals,
unlike some other species,
and because of that we need things that
kind of connects us in a social way.
So we have this social utility in which
we just care about other people now
that's create lots of problems.
For example,
if you do a favor to me,
I like you more and then it might put me
in,
in conflict of interest because they
would want to reciprocate in some way or
in a trust and revenge and all of those
things.
So the fact is that there are some
things that we are irrational and we
would have liked to fix it,
but there are some things where
irrationalities actually what allows us
to live in a society and if we lived as
individual organisms that basically had
no social ties and we're just working
each one of us separately,
it will be a very different social
structure,
but we might want to actually have
different strategies for decision
making.
But because we're inherently social
animals,
there's all kinds of things that make
that are irrational from the perspective
of thinking that everybody's a social is
a,
is a selfish maximizer,
but nevertheless make sense when you
think about people as social items.
The other thing of course is about
processing information.
So the fact is that we have a limited
brain,
you know,
we're kind of limited physically in many
ways,
right?
We can jump very high.
We can't sustain cold or heat.
I mean,
think about all the stuff in the world
that we do to make yourself more
comfortable.
We have chairs and clothes and glasses
and headphones.
I mean,
lots and lots of stuff.
It turns out our brain is also not
perfect,
right?
In the same way that our bodies are not
perfect,
we can't do everything we would like to
do.
We're not superman and our brain is also
not perfect.
Our brains process information in a
certain way,
and the reality that we experience is
not out there.
It's in here.
That's what gives us the.
The brain gives us the world brought to
us courtesy of our brain and it's
processing ability and because the brain
is not perfect,
the way we get information and process
it is also not perfect and that's just
kind of functional structural
limitations to how rational we can be.
And the fact is that we better recognize
if it's really good to recognize it,
understand the limitation,
then act accordingly.
Because if we don't,
we'll just make more and more mistake.
We'll just assume that we can be
perfect.
We'll create the world as if people
would create,
can be perfect.
And we'll just set ourselves to this
appointment time after time.